el descontento en Francia por la reforma
de pensiones no Da señales de
extinguirse
estas explicaciones del presidente
Manuel mccon al respecto en una inusual
entrevista televisada no hay 100
soluciones Si queremos que el sistema de
pensiones sea equilibrado ya no lo es y
Cuanto más esperemos más empeorará es
necesaria esta reforma no parecieron
convencer a los ciudadanos a
trabajadores y sindicalistas que
volvieron a salir a las calles este
miércoles
no me ha convencido en absoluto Cómo
podemos oír que la calle no tiene
legitimidad Cómo podemos oír Que a pesar
de todas las protestas la reforma de
pensiones se seguirá aplicando
Y es que a pesar de la gran movilización
en su contra el gobierno no piensa ceder
y lejos de una sensación conciliadora
desde la aplicación del 49.3 artículo
que usó El Ejecutivo para saltarse el
voto del parlamento el tono de las
protestas ha escalado al igual que la
indignación de los manifestantes que ya
tienen claro su próximo movimiento salir
a las calles hasta que se retire la
reforma
mañana saldremos de nuevo a las calles
para manifestarnos contra la reforma de
pensiones y exigir su retirada
hasta el final con bloqueos en el
transporte público los depósitos de
combustible y en la recolección de
basura Este es el mayor desafío que
enfrenta el gobierno en cuatro años
desde los chalecos amarillos no obstante
a pesar de que los sondeos muestran que
la gran mayoría de los franceses se
oponen a la reforma no se esperan
elecciones anticipadas ni una
remodelación del ejecutivo